en circunstancias habituales bocana
estaría a esta hora en el restaurante
donde trabaja como chef pero la
intuición que usa ha cambiado sus
prioridades
adiós en general han pasado dos semanas
desde que comenzó la guerra
y ahora que han empezado los
entrenamientos me siento mucho más
segura
como madre soltera fontana quiere estar
preparada para proteger a su hijo como
ella cada uno de estos voluntarios de
las unidades de defensa territorial
creen que si quieren conservar su país
tienen que protegerlo
siempre hemos estado preparados para la
agresión rusa desde 2014 supimos que don
bas y crimea no iban a ser sus últimos
objetivos
y bueno frank bis tiene trescientos mil
habitantes a pesar de que la guerra no
se siente como en otros lugares de
ucrania la vida está marcada por ella
como en este café donde apoyan a quienes
llegan de otras regiones
en lo personal me reúno con la gente que
muchas veces viene con ojos llorosos y
los apoyamos moralmente los calmamos le
decimos que todo va a estar bien
y éstos están por dónde
nicola tuvo que reaccionar rápido
después de la invasión la decisión
pasaba por mantener abierta su cadena de
pizzerías y los propietarios de
restaurantes decidimos organizarnos y
acordamos ayudar a militares voluntarios
y refugiados
ahora tiene la responsabilidad de
alimentar alrededor de 250 militares a
quienes provee dos veces al día
desde el principio de la invasión rusa
podemos sentir cómo la gente está unida
y cada uno apoya al ejército
la oficina de registro civil está más
ocupada que de costumbre decenas de
parejas han decidido casarse a última
hora muchos de ellos son militares que
tienen que ir a la guerra con las
situaciones que nosotros no sabemos qué
pasará mañana y estamos enamorados
queremos pasar el resto de nuestra vida
juntos para todos los planes han quedado
detenidos más nuevos sus sueños y por
eso luchan por protegerlos